ho finalmente siamo tornati su steve
white sono passate v tipo un anno nola
verranno no però l'anno scorso ho fatto
ultime foto di steve reich oggi la
facciamo in 33 milioni chi è compo che
sarebbe il ragazzo che ha fatto i terzi
in italia vi faceva lettera e quindi
abbiamo un buon motivo per spararsi
effettivamente buona visione
a nichi e il verde contro giallo che le
slot queste stick fai te lo presento
occhio occhiopinocchio molto colpita
ammoniti gigi l'ex pensate io lo sto
facendo ma che serve è questa roba qua
che spunta fuori una presa così le
fiamme grossi occhio di luciano terra
non si può che chiede un uomo che sa la
spaccata maiali ai amalgama
noto era troppo era troppo però niente
ma vabbè se non vi piace situazionali
sono morto sono morto da solo prima arma
tipo questa ciao ragazzi lei bellissima
occhio che qua a spazzare un attimo cosa
volevo fare lui d'altra parte se no non
l'ho preso vita di ricambio testa
saltando tipo
da cosa va dove ma dai imbarazzanti devi
stare o mio dio come dimostrano morto ha
vinto chi ha vinto ho vinto io esserci
avevo vinto io caro sco effettivamente
vero non è sofferente ma non so se avete
visto la miscela tristissimo famiglia
hai fatto una gran giocata mia appare
semplice così tifoso morto
consensi sei cambiata no oggi è niente
male eh si si io sono vivo io so no no
non lo so che vittoria ora che dal mio
passo la davano in piedi come impazzisco
e non è vero sono caduto sono subito le
scatole sono maledetto perchè siamo
tutte le tue rituali aiuto occhiali chi
che quella è una costruzione che se
prenderei di chi non chiedono è morto a
soli 2 comma di essere ancora vivo non
lo so guardami vivendo cosa che mi sento
come e non so cosa è successo era ancora
vivo
pittore inaspettati ma
a corpo che c'è ci sono era la copertina
di un mio vecchio video questo dai
piazzali uno che sta con i dolci estivi
a questi candidati
è l'appello è invece la gente ce l'ha
invece sì
oddio quella fortissima ma che casino
che ho fatto la mappa on
allora allora costone possiamo parlare
di sacco di un momento di imparare a
quello lancia piano quella e quello
lancia piano aiuto può fallire la beffa
bene allora di troveremo una soluzione
no no no no no hikari quando mi hai
fatto prendere il tè che ho copiato ci
sono già mi ricordo assolutamente di
quel sistema ricordo dei si sono
ricordati perché non hai studiato della
verifica interieur hanno avviato nel
periodo che è successo cosa è successo
ma serie cos'era sono viva di sotto so
pure con l'altra partita
cos'è stagione la terra è piatta abito
io perché tanto che il gran partita
resta ma vince chi rimane chiusura bene
ho visto il di allora e mi fa che ha
visto che qualcuno gioca con aiuto alla
compone passiamo a parlare quando buoni
proprio quando voi aiuto ai ferri al
live che è partita oddio mi sta
veramente difficile è vecchio casinò
hyun mi avete votato 18 si scompone
possiamo sempre parlare a posto
sono d'accordo con te stai per frey la
cordata mai detto che c'è una corona
niente migranti
e vabbè ancora dirlo che vuoi giocare
non so prendiamo un altro play a questo
ma dove sta questa l'audio non dico mai
ecco meno male che non vincevo mai a
raga io non so voi ma vi consiglio di
andare sotto e travasato conforto e cosa
ho fatto
si sa cosa vado bene verdi poi è caduto
prima tutto va bene e che male direi che
siamo a posto così e va bene mi sento
male aria
riecco la somma parco di mario faticoni
sono vivo io sono vivo come se com'è
possibile aspetto ad aver baciato
no è pagato michael ha giocato per forza
deve come hai fatto a sopravvivere la
spada la spada io la squadra non so se
tagliare il cappello questo si è
schiacciato ladri e schiacciata la dei
ragazzi è schiacciata l'attesa parte dei
big e stavo chef non ti volevo fare
niente ma perché ce l'hai con me o
cavalcanti rimango qua madonna che lo
sta e va beh allora che rinculo pazzesco
nichi si critica di torino purtroppo
come fai a essere vivo tutto cassetti è
possibile
[Musica]
ciao ragazzi possiamo parlare vediamo lo
più di tutti
si chiama che non ne parliamo proprio
vediamo che voglio io ma come ti ho
mandato sulla stratosfera
l'hack è male ma spaccato tutto l'asse
ragazzi stata così bloccata anche la cir
me no no ho fatto bene i sei a posto
tutto bene compro tutto sempre bene come
spa 1 york nella quale madonna infatti
aiutano tra di voi cosa youtube si è
sfondato aiuto ai a chiamare nominare ce
l'ha con me non ho fatto niente di male
sono vivo ma cosa va bene alla di
celiamo era visto evento che te l'ho
detto di gesù che cosa devo dire
ma possibile che io sono vivo aiuto è
diventato del cemento
ma non ci dicevano che non ci credo ma
dai ma l'ultima ragazzi di pilato di
fifa lei l'ha coronato esatto ed i
ciclisti voi mi capisce da questo
l'hacker male dell'a.ge la vittoria a
nichi da ancora una basta poi basta
l'ultima veramente basta no no ma feriti
hai detto che era lui la vince campo i
ragazzi questa è la sylphide di oggi
spero vi sia piaciuto vedete che il king
è in realtà non siamo stati bravi tutti
però pro niente però niente però invito
vi sia piaciuto a questo punto iscritte
via canale schiacciate il tasto mi piace
che trovate qua sotto e lasciate un
commento ovviamente cosa avete pensato
del video ci vediamo al prossimo video e
come sempre come che dico quella roba la
vigor
[Musica]